[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences
[music] of the individual. Results vary
and may not be typical. We do not make
any claims regarding health [music] or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of [music] epigenetics, Dr. Dr.
Joel Wallik, Bachelor of Science in
Plant and Soil Sciences, Doctor of
Veterary Medicine, for post-docctorates
in pathology, naturopathic doctor.
Hello and welcome everyone to Daily with
Doc and Becca. My name is Ruth Ellen
Sanchez and I'm going to be your host
today. And today we have a very special
guest, Dr. Richard Renton who is going
to be talking about men's health since
it's men's health month the prostate and
also talking about a new product that
Young has which is a on a hot topic
which I'm not going to disclose. So I'm
going to let him disclose that. Also
this program is for educational purposes
only. It is not meant to treat, diagnose
or cure any diseases. nor is it meant to
take the place of your primary care
physician. Any testimonials given are
given as personal experiences of the
giver. And
this is also a show that helps give you
options on how to care for yourself and
let your body do what it God intended it
to do and heal itself naturally on its
own with food and exercise and other
things. [clears throat] So, um, also
this program is sponsored by
dailywithdocbecca.com
or dailywithdoc.com, I'm sorry,
dailywithdoc.com.
And if somebody referred you to this
program, please get back with that
person. And I am going to bring Richard
on with me now and we are going to get
going.
Hello Richard.
>> How are you doing today?
>> I'm doing great. How are you?
>> Good, good, good. It's sunshiny here.
It's going to be in the high 70s or low
80s and the rain won't start till
tomorrow.
>> Excellent. [laughter]
[gasps]
>> That's good.
>> So, do you guys want me to take off or?
>> Sure.
>> Okay.
>> Yes.
>> So, Youngevity has introduced a new
product and we'll talk about it first.
And I think it's one that we needed
because we had a product like it. Um,
and this product's designed to kill
parasites in your body. And uh, people
didn't take it because it didn't taste
very good. And it was on the good herbs
family and and it was effective, but
people weren't taking it. And so we came
it out and it's called paracle clear. P
A R A C L A R E. And
sorry, my screen just went wacko on me.
And um it's got some pluses, but
basically I kind of want to talk about
how to use it first, then we'll talk
about the ingredients. And people will
was thought I was crazy and Joanne
Conaway, Dr. Joanne Conaway, we did a a
uh
audio cassette tape when they had those
things and CDs after that. And we talked
about how if you want to kill parasites,
the best way to do it is at full moon.
And people thought we were crazy that
they would say that our product worked
better is a full moon. And and that
really wasn't the case. But what is the
case is that parasites are more active
in your body during the full moon. So,
if you aggressively wanted to go after
them, you start the program about five
days before a full moon and you go to
about five days after a full moon. And
then you want to do that at least two
cycles in a row.
Uh because the parasites could have laid
eggs and during that period of time in
between the two cycles they may be
infant infiltrated into your body again.
And so you kind of have to do two cycles
in the row. And so the best way to do it
is follow the instructions. I think it's
one pill or two pills a day. And you
want to do that and start what full
moons in about 10 days. So you want to
start in about five days and then go
through the full moon and five more and
then rest for about 20 and then repeat
the cycle. And that's the best way to do
it because the parasites are more active
in your body. So, they're more willing
to absorb the nutrients that are in it
that will want them to either leave or
die. And some of those nutrients are uh
zinc and copper. They don't like those
two minerals in particular. But it also
has black walnut, worm worm wood. I have
trouble with that. Clover buds and
garlic. They hate all those. If you
think you have just parasites in
general, if you start eating garlic
every day, uh either by supplement or
more in your food, um that will work. I
don't recommend you grind up your your
walnut shells and eat black walnuts,
which is in it, because that's kind of
hard on your digestive system. So, doing
it via a dietary supplement seems to
work more effectively. And you can
travel with this because one of the big
things is people will pick up parasites
because their body's not used to it and
they go to a foreign country and then
hoo-ha and it doesn't make any
difference whether it's a person in the
United States going to I'm just going to
pick a country out. I'll just say
somewhere in Africa or vice versa. Both
are vulnerable because we're we haven't
built up these immune systems in the
various countries. So, it's a it's kind
of a smart product to travel with as
well. But the most common way to get a
parasite in the United States, maybe
South Africa is a little bit different,
but in America, is that we allow our
pets to kiss us in the face.
And most dogs and cats have parasites.
You can treat them, that's fine, but
they're going to have it. and and when
they they'll transfer it during that
sign of affection. And so that's the
easiest way to do it. So, first of all,
I'll tell you, don't let your dogs and
cats kiss you in the face. And second of
all, uh can you treat the dog or cat
with this product and put it in their
food? Yes. But you have to break up the
capsules in a proportion of the size of
the animal. So, let's consider your dog
is 50 pounds. then it' be a half a
capsule. It's 25 pounds. It's going to
be a quarter of a capsule. Now, it's all
blended, so they get the full benefit of
it, but you need to downsize it. If you
have a dog that's smaller than 25
pounds, then you probably should talk to
your vet about a product that's
specialized for a dog that small because
we we just don't want to overdo it with
them. But you can put it in their food
for them as well. Um, the other things
to keep in mind is Gardinia and tea tree
oil are great oils for your pets if you
put it on the scrub of their neck so
they can't lick it too much. Uh, but uh
that will help get rid of all sorts of
bugs that bother them on a regular basis
and you could take advantage of that.
So, it really is a neat product. Let's
see if I can if I go like this. The item
number, if you want to know, is 20972.
And it comes in our traditional white
bottle with a green cap. This isn't the
the the exact one cuz I don't even have
any yet. I won't get mine up here until
um for about another week. I think my
transfer is showing up, but it's pretty
much at the main warehouse. It's in
stock, and it's something that I really
recommend for all of you to take
advantage of. And so this month is
male month. We get, you know, in most of
our houses, you know, the women get
every room except for the garage and
maybe the basement. And so they get
every month except for June. And we get
to take claim for that one. And uh the
we I wanted to talk about some of the
challenges that men have um in general
and what we can do about it. Uh the
probably the most common one that people
talk about is prostate problems and they
kind of come in two stages.
You could you either have an enlarged
prostate
or you could have prostate cancer. And
they're they we kind of go after them in
two different directions. Prostate's one
of those cancers that are there's about
five or six different varietals
and almost all of them grow very slowly.
There is one strain out there though
that is very aggressive in its growth.
And just to give you an example, I had
the one and I was lucky. I had the one
out of five that grow very fast and they
were estimating it was doubling in size
every 3 to four months in my body. So, I
took a little more of an aggressive
program because I was in my 50s when it
happened and I wanted to live to be at
least in my 70s because that's when I am
now and I just soon stick around for a
little bit longer. And um we we went
about it more aggressively. But if
you're showing signs of an enlarged
prostate, which you know is discomfort
down there, uh, uh, problems with
urination and things like that, you
know, more information makes it
available for you to make more
intelligent decisions. And I'll still
tell you to consult your health care
professional. Um, he may just take PSAs.
I think anyone over the age of 35, it's
a male should take a PSA every year, no
matter what. Now, no matter how old they
are. Um, former President Biden's
learning that lesson the hard way
because uh, according to his wife, she
she they were informed that once you
reach the age of 70, you don't need to
take it anymore. I think that philosophy
is if it's the slow dying the slow
growing type, you'll probably die of
something else first. But he is in stage
four with prostate cancer right now and
has to deal with that. What that
basically means, it's no longer in his
prostate. It's also in the lymph nodes
and bones in that area of his body. So
he definitely has an uphill uh battle
with this particular challenge. But so
we break it into two sections and
enlarged prostate and then prostate
cancer. And as health as advisors on
nutritional products, we can't say that
we can cure it. We can't say we can
overcome it or any of that. But I will
talk about some areas that you can go
and get some research and then link it
to some of our products so that you can
do your own due diligence with all of
that. Uh the first thing that I
recommend is we'll hold we'll hold it
up. It's called Prost FX. It has the
most common ingredient that you'll see
in almost all prostate products out
there called SA Palnto. And it also has
pyia and some other nutrients in it. But
it's designed to shrink a prostate. And
uh in doing so, if you can shrink the
size of the prostate, the chance of you
growing uh cancer cells is uh strongly
reduced.
We also have it with in the good herbs
family. I would say that it's stronger,
but it doesn't taste good. And the one
thing I I've learned over the years that
men are much more willing to I don't
take the product because it tastes bad
and I'll live with it or I'll stick my
head in the sand. And so if you can't
get them to take this one, then go back
to this one. Now, I've heard Doc on
lectures talk about when you're in your
your 50s, you should always take one of
these. When you're in your or excuse me,
40s, you should always take one of
these. When you're in your 50s, you take
two. when you're in your 60s, you take
three, and when you're in your uh 70s,
you take four. Um, and so that being
said, it helps reduce it. AJ, did you
have a question you want to toss out at
me right off the bat?
>> I had a commentary, but I can wait.
>> Okay. Um, so
this is my favorite because I can get
everyone to take a couple pills. This
one will actually if you have an extreme
case is more effective but it's not the
best tasting. The other thing is that
dealing with men and this is just
because I'm an athletic trainer. They
think if two pills is great, four is
better and eight is even better than
that no matter what. Well, that might be
okay with the Prostep X, but don't do
that with the tinctures. This product
line, the good herbs product line, this
is all of their products was designed
for health care professionals to uh uh
diagnose and treat in their office and
recommend to their patients in their
office. So, this is already strong.
So, taking twice as much is not going to
improve the performance of the product.
Just take what it recommends. I want to
say it's going to be two milliliters,
which is a relatively small amount. It's
a half a teaspoon. And I will tell you,
put it in your mouth, swallow, and don't
think about it. And you know, just
remember when you were a child, your mom
told you had to take cod liver oil. And
that's exactly what you did. You put in
your mouth and didn't think about it,
right? And so it's what I suggest. Now,
let's say it's gone farther and you're
suspecting because your PSA is moving
around. Um PSA,
which is a blood test looking for some
particular hormones within your body.
Just because it's high doesn't mean you
have prostate cancer. What they're
really looking for is movement upwards
especially. And so getting just one is
not the best way to do it. That's why
they you should start young, get it
every year so you get this track record
of what's going on. So if you're let's
say you're 22 22 26,
you then know you have a challenge and
you can start looking at it. And if
that's the case, you know, I'm gonna I'm
gonna go against the natural grains. I'm
going to tell you get a biopsy and which
is not a fun experience. They're going
to take 12 samples. Um, and then they'll
test it. And those particular 12 areas
of your prostate and they'll look for
cancer cells within those 12, odds on
favor, if you have cancer, they'll run
into a cancer cell. And depending on how
many zones you are, they'll rate it and
they'll be able to identify on what type
of prostate cancer it is if you have it.
And then you can determine what you can
do. And I'll be the first person that
says if you get if you go to a biopsy
and it's positive, don't say whatever
you say you're the doctor. Go do your
due diligence. Read about all the
different options you have. you know, if
it's slow growing in your 80s, you may
not take an option if you're if you're
only at stage one. Uh if you're like me,
stage four, then you want to do it. But
there's so many new treatments that are
coming out, you know, uh mine was 20
years ago, there was really only two or
three uh methods, but now there's four
or five that you can do as well as just
trying supplements to be beneficial.
There is certain nutritional ingredients
that seem to be effective. You can go to
pubmed.gov
pudme.gov
go V and that's the United States
Library of Medicine and you can put in
uh prostate cancer and an ingredient
like fucquitin for example and read
about what it says about it uh helping
to reduce the speed of the cancer or
otherwise and it's in there and we
actually have a couple products that
have it uh coincidentally both kind of
named the same fucoidon and fucoid
which is one's a capsule, one's a
liquid. Obviously, this one has super
juices in it, so it's very palatable, so
you can't have that excuse. Uh, and one
of the ladies that brought this to us,
because this came from an outside
company that became part of Youngevity,
actually had the men taking both forms.
Um, I can't answer really why, but she
says it just seemed with her experience
in the 10 years that they were having to
think. Um and so you may consider that
as an option. Uh Dr. Wallik used to do
some research on uh various cancers and
prostate cancer was one of them and he
did a study in China where they had high
levels of prostate cancer and he
increased their dosage to 250 micrograms
of selenium
and saw a decrease of cases showing up
within this region. And he was actually
published on that one. So if you go to
pubmed.gov
and you type in selenium and prostate
cancer or just cancer, you'll find
studies that he did years ago with Dr.
Mlan uh in that uh and they looked for
areas in the world that were unusually
high in a particular type of cancer and
then they go into that area and they did
it and he did it primarily with selenium
and zinc is also beneficial. The other
thing that I I tell people is read about
what activating your white blood cells
and getting them more active within your
body. Um, will it help with the cancer?
And we have a product called R Y L Beta
550. If I hold I'll hold it closer to my
face so it's in focus. Uh, that does
just exactly that. uh and typically in
your body only about a third of the
white blood cells are active at any one
given time. And so if and you know they
help with infections and things like
that and if you were to increase that to
70% or doubling more than doubling the
number that's that's beneficial to
those. The other thing I'll tell you is
that your a male's prostate is a dirty
organ. Um, and if you live long enough,
I'll almost guarantee that you'll get
prostate cancer. Now, it may happen in
your 50s, may happen in your 60s, 70,
80s, 90s, or whatever, but it's just one
of those things. And so, you know, when
men were only living to be 50 years old,
prostate cancers a lot of the times
never showed up during that period of
time. But now that the average age is up
in the upper 70s, low 80s, depending on
where you are, um, it's showing up more
and more. And so we just need to be a
little more reactive. You know, take
that 215 micrograms of selenium to
prevent uh keep your eye on PSA. If it
starts moving around and going up in an
upward trend, then you might want to get
a biopsy just to know what you're
facing. It's, you know, is there risks
involved with the biopsy? The answer to
that is yes, but not nearly as bad as if
you have prostate cancer and you don't
do anything about it. And so I think
that you can do it. Can you go to get
different opinions? Absolutely. I tell
you, you know, if you're going to do
your own research, you don't have to
believe me. Please do your research and
do it. But just remember, half the stuff
on the internet's not true. So, make
sure you understand what where the
source comes from to make an intelligent
decision on what to do. uh if you know
if you look at the natural way and it's
on 15 different websites to do this this
and this and they're all exactly the
same odds on favor is a relatively good
source. If it seems to be bizarre and
you can only find one person that says
it then you know be careful on what you
wish for. So that being said for
prostate cancer um I hope no one gets
it. That's the best way I can do it. The
other thing I'll tell you is if you have
a spouse, keep her in the loop on what's
going on because the decisions that you
guys are going to make and it'll affect
her life too. Just as if she has breast
cancer, if she didn't share it with you
as a male, you'd be upset about the
situation. You you know, you're a
partner. It's a it's a relationship. So,
plea please do that. The other thing
that um I usually get telephone calls on
is uh men and hormone problems just like
women and hormone problems and they seem
to uh have challenges with their
testosterone levels decreasing uh as
well as melatonin and other hormones
that are within your body. And it's not
unusual the older you get that the
weaker those are. Uh studies show that
usually in your 30s at some time you'll
start to lose
I apologize.
>> We couldn't hear it at all.
>> Oh, cool. Uh I apologize u for that. Uh
but anyways, uh that you'll start your
levels of testosterone will start to
decrease. uh you can usually tell it
happens without getting a test even
though you can get a blood test. Uh just
because you're not as strong as you do,
your energy level isn't as much, your
libido isn't as much. You know, you just
start to feel not as like you did in
your 20s. Well, you know, if you talk to
someone and says, "Well, no one's going
to feel like they're in their 20s."
Well, that's probably because your
hormones aren't really balanced. And so,
you can delay that by uh taking products
that submit uh hormone balances within
your system. And probably the one I like
the better, I didn't bring it in here,
is Zeia test uh to be beneficial with
that product. Now, it's a combination of
two different things. It's a combination
of immortalium, which supports telomeir
health, and then hormone balancer for
men, which obviously helps balance the
hormones. Um, we don't have a standalone
product to raise your testosterone
level. Um, I really don't know why, but
we've never gone down that angle, so I
can't recommend something in that area.
But I can tell you by eating better
foods, more green foods, uh, by taking
collagen and working out on a daily
basis, at least 20 minutes worth of
walking a day, that you're going to
maintain uh, bone structure and muscle
tone much longer than if you sit in a
chair, as I'm doing right now, staring
at people on screens. Uh so that being
said, um you know, go for it. Uh the
other one too I should say is that with
the good herb products, there is a male
hormone. Hold it close to my face so
it's in focus. Maybe lean forward. Uh
and it has an herbal formula. All the
good herb products are primarily herbal
formulas and it'll be beneficial. But
also make sure you're taking the
mighty90 whether it's the simplest form
with Probo Omega and Ultra Body Totty or
one moving up to one of our healthy
start packs. Just getting good basic
nutrients is good and stay away from the
bad foods which I'm sure you guys have
all heard at 100 different times. But,
you know, cola, alcohol, uh deep fried
foods, uh excessive fat, especially when
it's exposed to temperatures, uh that
turn it into rancid fat, uh and things
like that. And so, if you take care of
yourself, you'll have a much happier
life. uh and you can look at enjoying
your 70s and 80s and 90s and maybe even
100. And that's what I hope for all of
you. So, that's kind of what I wanted to
talk about as far as that. I'm sure
everyone always has questions. I know if
AJ had a chance, he would have his
little hand up symbol shaking because
he's got so many lined up, but why don't
we open it up for questions and see
where people want to go with this.
Go AJ.
>> AJ, go ahead.
I just I just have one question. Um,
our friend Adrian Gold
talks about uh
um
>> the ProAba product for it.
>> It's called uh Prostat.
>> Yes.
>> What are your thoughts on Prostat?
So Prostat is the pollen that he really
liked that comes out of Sweden. I've
actually been to their facilities and he
did some studies with it and and saw
some positive results. Um, you know,
everyone has their preferences, right?
So Corey designed that product. I
designed this product. I should hold it
with the label going forward. Uh, and so
we all have our personal preferences.
Um, if you want to try if this doesn't
do anything for you, then try it. Or if
you want to try the ProStat and it
doesn't do anything for you, switch over
to this one. It's okay, but everyone has
their personal favorites.
>> I do use um
I have used Pro uh Pro Staff on a number
of occasions. And then the second uh one
when you're talking about testosterone,
I've used I use on a daily basis the
stay balanced.
What are your thoughts on that one?
>> Yep. That could be beneficial. But I got
a question for you. Have you next time
you take a series and if you get free
health care have a
>> next time I take a series
>> a series of prostat a prob balance take
a take a testosterone test before you do
it and then go on it for a few months
and then take it and see if there's a
difference and try to keep everything
else in your life about the same because
I know you work out on a regular basis.
I know you eat smart on a regular basis.
>> No, no. I'm not Coach Rod. No, no, no,
>> no, no, no, no, no. Oh, everybody's got
to do that. I just assumed [laughter]
[clears throat]
>> and and eat the best foods, you know,
and and see if there's only one major
change and that's that pro balance, then
yeah, go for it and then recommend it to
your friends, you know, uh it's kind of
like the stay clear. I know it's going
to work. I just I look at the
ingredients and I just know that
product's going to work uh if you do it
right. And so with so many of our
products when we designed it, I I know
in most cases this is going to be
effective with the prostate. Uh but in
testosterone in men
more it's it's not 80% of the people and
so it's always interesting and I don't
believe in artificial testosterone for
men either. So the shots and whatnot
that's not I'm not a big fan of that
either. Well, uh, apparently
the, uh, zero test is very popular for
people who go to the gym.
>> That that's a very extremely popular one
for gym goers.
>> So there again, I'll I'll ask two
questions on that and you'll probably
understand this one. Is it going to the
gym
that made the difference or was it the
product that made the difference?
>> I think they were already going to the
gym.
>> Okay.
>> And then they had the product introduced
to them.
>> And so I'd be also be interested to see
when they start increasing their
collagen levels and things like that,
what is that going to do to their
hormones when we come out with the
collagen product?
>> A collagen product tied to hormonal
health.
>> Yeah.
Because if all of a sudden you start
increasing muscle mass and things like
that and you're holding your muscle
mass, you're going to go work out more
because it's going to excite you. And I
think working out's really important.
>> And I don't know, I may have missed it.
Did you have anything to do with the
formulation on the uh on the new um
parah product? No, but we used to have
one a long time ago and that was my
design and this one isn't much
different. There's a couple different
things that we added, but other than
what that it's basically the same. And I
don't know why I picked up the bottle
because I don't have the bottle yet.
This is the other product. Um, but it
looked more official, I guess. Um, and
so, uh, yes and no. Uh, but Steve and I
have done a couple different products
over the years and and this one just
seems to be really strong.
>> Thank you.
>> But the key is really taking it close to
a full moon.
>> Yeah, that's very important. Yeah,
>> I've been studying herbology and
different things for since like 1980
something. And every time somebody talks
about doing a cleanse for years now,
they always do it around the full moon.
And
I mean, [laughter] I don't know what it
is, but it makes them more active. But
the moon affects so many things. It's
really interesting to me. So we did you
have something to say about that part
because I have questions.
>> No, go go go ahead.
>> Oh, no. If you because I'm always
curious what makes them move around
more. Okay. So I have somebody on Zoom.
Their name is Sam and um he is 60 years
old, 158 pounds and his PSA is three.
says, "I avoid 12 bad foods
and daily intake, BTT,
EFA plus, gluccoel, osteo effects, sweet
and sweet ease. What YGY products can I
add
to get more of zinc, pickolinate, and
vitamin E? I don't get any beta citizol
in my current protocol. Thanks.
>> Damn from PA.
>> Oh, he's getting it. He's getting it in
his BTT.
>> Okay.
>> He could go and get the straight zinc
uh product that we have.
Zinc and more. What was the other thing?
um
gonna add zinc
and vitamin E.
>> It's kind of interesting. He doesn't
think he's getting enough vitamin E. I
wonder if he's not absorbing it well.
>> Maybe he just thinks he needs to take
more than what's in the BTT and the
other products.
>> Yeah. Um so here's my first thing.
>> I could see if you will unmute and maybe
you can ask him. Sam, would you like to
unmute and ask your question?
>> There you go.
>> Hey, Sam, did you get a hair sample test
or did you take get a blood test?
>> Oh, Sam, if you're talking, we can't
hear you. Try um turning up your volume
or
in the audio settings at the bottom of
the screen next to little microphone,
you should be able to select whatever
microphone you're using.
So,
um,
check that and then raise your hand.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> Yes. Perfect.
>> Great. Great. Thanks. I can't figure out
how to get my Oh, there's maybe here.
There we go. There we go. Okay. Got it.
Thanks.
>> You're welcome.
>> Yeah.
>> So, why do you think you have low E and
low zinc? I was just I was referencing
um
uh Dr. Ben or pharmacist Ben had a
little post out about um some those
three things um the uh vitamin E of 400
IU and 300 to 400 of betaol and uh seven
50 milligrams of zinc. So, I was looking
at some of the products I was taking and
didn't notice that I didn't think, maybe
I'm wrong, but I didn't think they
reached that level. And then I didn't
know if longevity had a beta cytol
product or not. And I was just
referencing what he had said in one of
his short videos.
>> Okay. Um, and you can call uh Ben doctor
because he also has a PhD.
>> Okay. Um, and so, uh, so I'm quickly
looking because I don't want to
misquote. Uh, zinc immune support has 10
milligrams of, uh, zinc in it, but we
have more than one. So, let me do the
other one. And, um,
and let it come up. And that's the zinc
drops.
If I can get it to come up. And let's
see now a dropper full
has five. So I'd probably go to the zinc
immune. I don't know if you if you're
getting the BTT and whatnot, you don't
have to take like five of those pills,
but you you can increase it there. As
far as the vitamin E, when people in my
experience
and uh when they don't think they're
getting enough vitamin E that's already
in the BTT, I wonder if they have a
healthy gut. And so one of the things
you may try to do just to see how your
absorption going is to get some of the
I26 products.
>> Okay.
>> Which kills the bad bacteria. Has anyone
talked recently about I26?
>> I don't think so.
>> Okay. So I26 is derived from an egg
membrane. You know when you have a
chicken egg and you break it open and
there's that really skin thin layer
that's always on the egg that you always
peel off. uh it's actually derived from
that. Chickens
quite commonly have the same bacteria in
their gut that we do as humans. And but
they've found a way to get rid of the
bad bacteria. And so we found out if
when you take the I26, it's going to
kill the bad bacteria but not harm the
good bacteria in your gut. So if you
kind of think of the legal scales,
right, and you have
50 billion cultures in you and it's
2525, good versus bad, you're you're
kind of in the middle here. But how how
good does your absorption get if you can
get rid of 25% or 50% of the bad
bacteria and increase your good bacteria
by 25 50%. And most people understand
that taking a probiotic is a smart thing
to do. P and probiotics and absolutely
but but taking with them or just even
stand alone for a few months I26 to get
rid of the bad bacteria in your gut.
It's there is no adverse side effects to
it period unless you're all allergic to
chicken eggs. Um that it's a great way
to absorb better all your nutrients
whether it's from your diet or from your
nutritional products and then you don't
have to load yourself as much. So,
>> okay,
>> almost everybody that I bring into
Youngevity, the first month I put them
on something that will improve their gut
because everything costs money this day
and I wanted want you to get the best
bang. Yes, I want you to feel better if
you feel bad, but the first thing I
typically do is work on their gut for a
month and get it healthy with pre and
probiotics and I26 and maybe some
initial nutrients. And then after the
first couple of months when I think
their but gut's a lot healthier, then
we'll start addressing everything else.
Because if I give you, you know, Beyond
Tangy Tangerine and glucco gel and
collagen and extra EFAs and all this and
your gut's not in good shape, it's just
going to flush out of your system.
>> Okay.
>> And I don't want that. And so, okay,
>> I'm a big
>> You have any comment on the um I've seen
that advertised a lot in different areas
for men's health is the uh beta cytool.
>> Yeah. Um, I know we have it in some of
their products, but now that it's over
200 products, I don't know which one
it's in.
>> Right. But just
>> what I will do is when I'm on next
month, and Ruth Ellen can buzz the date
off, but I have to look over at my
calendar. Uh, I'll go through everything
and find everything that's got it and
then we'll talk about it when I come on
next month. Is that a good enough deal?
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> Cool.
>> Yep. That'll be July 22nd.
>> Great.
Thank you, Sam.
>> All right.
>> Very good. And then, um, Hattie has her
hand up, so we're going to go to Hattie,
and then I have a couple more, uh,
questions from on, um, Zoom, uh,
YouTube, and some other platforms. So,
I'm going to ask you to unmute, Haddie.
>> Awesome. [clears throat]
Good afternoon. I was getting ready to
lower my hand because um I had I was
Anyway, I was getting ready to lower my
hand because I because my questions got
confused. But in any event, just one
thing I just want you to to to clarify
or to deepen my understanding. You say
the prostate is a dirty organ
and instinctively I said, "Well, God
don't make nothing dirty, so there must
be something to this." And I really want
to understand what you mean by that.
>> So everything that goes out of your
digestive system goes through the uh
prostate and our diet is crummy. Typical
American diet is crummy
and the Europeans are catching up to us
and the Australians are catching up to
us and all that. And it's because that
everything passes through there that it
just has a chance to pick up fecal
matter within the organ itself. And so
if we can prevent uh urine and and all
the bacteria that's in there from going
through, uh that's why I call it a dirty
organ. Uh not that it's a bad organ, you
know, it's just like the pancreas or or
the gallbladder. They all have purposes.
Uh it's just that it seems like, you
know, uh we all know if we have a liver
and we drink too much, it's going to
wear out faster. We I just know if you
live long enough, your your a male
prostate will wear out. Is that fair
enough?
>> Oh, yes. That's gross. So, you can't
just not So, there's not a there's not a
cleanse for the prostate. There's a
cleanse for everything else.
Well, that's part of what Prostx does is
is to reduce the the uh size of the
prostate so that you have free urination
and things like that. And then eating a
better diet.
You know, when when I was young, I
remember when we would go on picnics and
whatnot, we had those paper plates that
divided into three sections and one of
them is like twice the size as the other
two. Do you remember that?
>> Yes. Yes. and we always put the meat or
the chicken or whatever the main part in
that section. Well, realistically, if
you still keep with that idea, but that
bigger section is all greens, fruits,
and vegetables,
and the smaller section is the protein,
and then even the smaller section is the
carbohydrates,
and get more of your diet towards the
Mediterranean style. overall
healthywise, you'll be fine. You know,
the French have far less cancer than the
Americans do. Uh, and this is just an
example. And they still smoke a lot
compared to the United States. How's
that so? Well, we know that they take
they drink wine and they get reservatrol
from wine, but they also eat much more
fruits and vegetables than we do. And
almost they don't know they don't have
nearly the big stores over there like we
do over here. They're all those little
farmer markets where you go out, you get
that day's food and you consume that day
food. You don't go to Costco and buy
your 25 pound bag of lettuce leaf. You
know, it's just a more effective and
better way of doing it. And if we can
kind of take from the good, not the beat
up Costco. I go to Costco. Uh but uh to
take advantage of that, you'll be
healthier.
>> Okay. And so when you talked about
the new
um
>> paracleans,
>> no not even so much that the the the
prostate one because you said it was
similar to the good herbs the good herbs
brand but the good herb the good herbs
is much stronger than the than um prost
that
>> prostep x.
>> Okay. So you don't have to take both.
You just choose your preference.
Correct. And typically I start the men
on this and then if it doesn't increase
the swelling of the prostep X, we might
go to the to the u um good herb formula
or we might go to the probable formula.
>> Okay. And and lastly, you mentioned that
we should that not we but men should be
taking
um like a a beta glucan. You said r
>> if
if they're showing signs of
>> cancer
>> cancer, you know, we're not supposed to
diagnose prescribed. Uh I'm telling you
just so we're quote we won't get in
trouble. Go to pubmed.gov and start
reading about it. And they may want to
make a decision to do that. And if they
do, this is the product.
We have to abide by their rule because I
don't have a PhD after my name.
>> Awesome. Thank you so very much.
>> Thank you very much, Haddie.
All right, AJ has his hand up.
All right, Richard, on unrelated topic,
um, you have a sign behind you that says
Youngevity
established
April 15, 1996.
>> Correct. Explain to me why next year is
the 30th anniversary.
[laughter]
>> No, next year we're celebrating the 30th
anniversary
and the that's the date we first started
to ship products.
>> April 15th.
>> Uhhuh. Um.
Yes. And uh so
if you don't know the story, Doc and his
wife and Steve and his wife and myself
and my wife then uh we were working for
another company and Doc actually owned a
third of that company and he wanted
additional products and they said uh the
company said no, we're not going to do
that. And we were all having dinner up
in Portland, Oregon. And Doc was
kitching. If you if you know you're
Yiddish, you know what I'm saying. And
uh and my wife turned around and says,
"Well, Richard has a degree in that. Why
don't you just have him make it for
you?"
And uh Steve looked at me and Doc looked
at me and then all of a sudden here we
came out started to come out with
products.
At that time, Doc's commissions were
extremely high because 80% of the
signups of the company were directly in
his downline because he was going out
lecturing all over the United States and
he was having rooms with five and 600
people in it, right? And uh doing his
lecture, dead doctors don't lie. So he
he was growing the company by come by
leaps and bounds. Well, the company
decided that they didn't want to pay him
commission anymore and the easiest way
to do that is just to fire him.
And so the day they fired him, and this
is December of 95,
um they fired Steen, Michelle, and they
fired, you know, Roxan and myself. And
so Doc came to us and says, "Well, I got
all these lectures still set up. I'm
going to do the lectures, but I need you
to guys to get our own company going."
And so Steve and Michelle moved down to
San Diego, and Steve developed the comp
plan, uh, and all that part. Michelle
got all the staff. uh they found a
facility that they could initially store
it and my job was to come up with about
the first 18 products to sell and to
find the vendors to make it for us and
and to meet the specs to go in front of
Doc and then back then it was Dr. Edwin
Dwis and Dr. Ghart Shrouser and justify
all the formulas that I came up with
which was kind of an interesting
experience for me. I felt like I was
getting a masters and it was in front of
my my board of trustees telling me what
I was nuts. Uh but it was it was
interesting and we and we basically did
it in four months which is really
unheard of and we kind of shocked the
area on it and and yes we did sue the
first company for wrongful termination
and all that kind of stuff. And uh uh by
the time it went to uh arbitration, uh
the arbitrator says, "You really don't
have a case here because you guys have
already started your your own company
and you can't show me damages because
you're making more money now." And so
what ended up happening is we just
absorbed that company. We just put them
out of business and they became our
products.
And so now products like Ultrabody Totty
are under our label.
So there's the story on that. But yeah,
April 15th when the first product
started to go out.
>> So all of the Ultra products were the
the legacy pre-ungeevity products.
>> Yeah. The uh Total Body Totty, the uh uh
Ultra Body Totty, Kids Totty, D-stress,
that group was originally a company. We
basically sued them, took them out of
business, and they became part of us
because they couldn't pay us.
>> Yeah. Oh, Richard, we learn so much
every time you're on. This is
>> Yeah. I'm waiting for the time that I
that that I get a Steve Wallick beep on
my my bat phone, so to speak, and he
says, "What are you talking about that
stuff for?" You know,
>> that's [laughter] funny.
That's funny.
That's a very interesting story. Uh,
thank you for sharing that. So, um, and
then Phyllis has her hand up, so we're
going to go to Phyllis.
Thank you, Phyllis. Let me add you.
Thank you so much.
>> And Phyllis remembers the pre-ungeevity
days.
>> Uh, I I think we actually came on board
right at the start of the new of
Youngevity, but I do remember those days
well. [laughter]
Um, so Miriam has a question. Can the
Paraclear be taken even if you don't
think you have parasites? Kind of like
insurance. And part two of the question
is, how often would you repeat that
two-month process of taking the paracle?
>> Can you? Yes, but I'd probably still do
it in the 10-minute windows or not
10-minute minute windows, 10 day windows
around the full moon, the five days
before and five days after.
>> Right. Right.
>> And I wouldn't go over one capsule a
day.
>> Okay. One capsule [clears throat] a day,
10 days before and after the full moon.
>> Right. And then two months, and then I'd
probably take three or four months off,
then you two months again if you think
you still have the parasites.
>> So, it works well as a preventative, in
other words. Yeah.
>> All right. Thank you so much. Good
seeing you.
>> Good seeing you, too.
>> Okay. All right. Did I forgot to ask
you, do you have a hard stop?
>> Oh, 10 minutes or so.
>> Okay. All right. Because I have a couple
questions and Key has her hand up, so I
just want to make sure to get to um
So, uh Cynthia, I believe on YouTube
says, "I have a friend who had prostate
surgery and since then he has had he has
been wearing depens because his urine is
just flowing incessantly. Anything can
be done."
Sounds awful.
>> Probably not. There is on the market
that we don't have some um bladder uh
products that might be beneficial to
her. Oh, just to kind of fill people in,
in surgery, um, when they remove it,
there's a major nerve that goes through
the prostate and then when a male has
two sphincters in that part of his body
that helps him control urinary flow, the
first spinure once the urine's strong
enough and it goes through, tells your
brain that you need to go to the
restroom, and your second spiner stops
it until you get there. So if you remove
one then then that's why he has he has
the tra problem with urination. Some of
the times when they do the surgery
method um they um
hit that particular situation because of
what's around [clears throat] there and
remove it and then yes is there anything
that can actually stop it? No. Um I'm
not that I'm aware of stopping it. there
is some products out there that will uh
ease the flow a little bit and he just
has to kind of do his due diligence on
that one.
>> Okay,
thank you.
And then um Oh, where did my thing go?
All right. And then
Charmaine
is
okay. I think you just answered
Charmaine's question. Um,
>> is it Charmaine Murphy?
>> Wait, I think it's she's using it's on
YouTube. No.
>> Oh, okay.
>> YouTube. So, I'm not sure because you
know they different not always.
>> It's Char Murphy. Hello.
I don't I don't think it is because it
says if someone already had prostate
removed how can they manage that aspect
and that was from around 345s.
So I guess that could I think
>> so Keele exercises and I think almost
all women know about Keele exercise well
men can do it too and they get their
muscles stronger in that part of their
body that will help in some way. Will it
stop it? No. Uh but if if you know if
you can reduce the amount of depends to
three a day down to one a day that would
probably make life a little more
pleasant for them. Uh and so just the
core exercises and things like that and
just working out. You know you can turn
out to do kele exercises anywhere
because this is just kind of tightening
and hold the tightening of the certain
muscles and then relaxing and just
repeat that process.
>> Okay. And the Bruce commented at 3:35,
"Ultimate microbiome or ultimate
enzymes. If a customer is taking the 90
and trying to save money, what one or
two products should I recommend for a
gut health secret sauce?"
>> I would I would the first month I would
go on I26 and after that switch over to
the microbiome.
>> Okay. Microbiome. [clears throat]
So microbiome has a half dose of I26
plus enzymes and probiotics and so I
would go after the bad bacteria and then
I would go back to something that will
maintain.
>> Okay. I believe it also has lion's mane
in it.
>> Wonderful. All right. So Keely,
if you could
unmute yourself, that would be awesome.
Thank you.
>> Hi Richard. How are you, dear?
>> I'm doing well.
>> Um, I'm going to go back to the subject
of hand because, you know, I'm like a
purist when it comes to Dr. Wallik. Um,
uh, I had a couple I had three or four
clients that had prostate cancer. Um,
two of which went through a surgery and
two of which did not. Um, because we
were really sort of hunkering down. And
doc did the original two protocols and
that was you know he said look he goes
take a step back because prostate cancer
is not a genetic disease and it's not
inevitable he says a consequence of
aging he said basically you know this is
a deficiency in the body that can be
addressed and he also went off on the
PSA test you know is a disaster that 98%
of it was basically a false positive you
know which is why those two individuals
did not have their surgery. They went
from one went from a 10.6
down to the range of three and has
maintained now for almost two years. Um
the other one was at about an 8.9 and is
sitting right now at about um I think
it's 3.5. So those are real successes.
on the other end. Um my one client who
had the surgery um has had the leaking
problem and with the kagel exercises and
then with the additional protocol of
rebuilding you know with the glucagel
the collagen the MSM whatever he was
able to recover the fact that he no
longer leaks. So that was really a
protocol that Doc had given me um over
two years ago. Um just I just
>> I'll reach out to Doc before next month
and ask him from a biochemistry
thing and and I'm a guy that gets into
that. I don't know how MSM
would improve or enhance. Collagen is
just going to help with the flexibility
of his connective tissue. So I can I can
see that argument, but the MSM I don't
understand. So I'll try to reach out to
him and get an answer on that.
>> Okay. And then the other thing was is
that when we were talking about the
biopsies, you know, doc said, "Look, you
know, if you do a biopsy, he says that's
really releasing, you know, the
prostaglandon." And he goes, you know,
he was really um you know, you know how
Doc is. He's a pure he's a purist. And
so he's like, you know, you really need
to consider what the side effects of
that are. And I just shared that with my
clients and that's how the other two
made a decision, you know, not to have
that surgery, recognizing the doctors
were telling them they wanted to cut it
out and cut it off. Um, you know, so I
just share that that, you know, with
four different clients, obviously the
majority of them are having positive
outcomes. Um, the other individual has
some heart issues now. um as a result I
guess he is told of having um um part of
that surgery and the release of the
prostaglandins. So just a different
perspective to sort of hold out the
whole thing.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you Keely.
>> You bet. Thank you for
all right and AJ.
>> Hey Richard, this [clears throat] is not
my question. Uh, not because um I don't
I'm not curious about the question. It's
just not my question. This is a question
from a woman named Marilyn,
not our Marilyn, another Marilyn and
asks uh
ask Richard, do parasites
cause cancer?
Not my question. Yeah, I'm thinking
about this one.
Can they? Yes. Do I think that everyone
that gets parasites is going to get
cancer? I don't think that's a true
story.
So, I'll say it could, but it's not
likely. And then I'll do more due
diligence.
>> You you have seen the things.
>> Can you get blood toxicity? Can blood
toxicity cause cancer? Yes.
um you know there's some side effects
that they do
that creates problems but I wouldn't I
think that the parasites cause certain
things in your your body that if you
don't take care of can down the road
cause more problems
and that's kind of how I want to answer
that one. I don't think there's a direct
correlation to a particular parasite
causing cancer in your body. But you
know, like ticks, do ticks cause Lyme
disease or is it the bacteria they put
in your body causes Lyme disease?
Because right now in the United States,
East Coast, I'm not East Coast, Lyme
disease is a big deal.
>> It is
because the reason I guess she's asking
the question is there is a contention
online. And you know if you read
Facebook and Instagram and these things
that says that all cancer is caused by
parasites
that I don't believe.
Not all. Um but
you know there again they're if they
poison your blood are you going to have
problems? Yes.
>> Thank you AJ. You know that I don't
think there's an absolute AJ. I think
you and I can eat the same food, work
out the same time, spend the same amount
of quality time recreation, the same
amount of quality time working, and
different things are going to happen to
us because we're all different. And you
know the given absolute like everyone
that has a parasites going to have
cancer or anyone that got cancer has
parasites. I don't know if I agree with
that just because it's an absolute.
I agree with you
because you never know what's gonna
happen to anyone. [laughter]
All right. So, um I do have a comment
made by one of our YouTube listeners or
viewers, I should say. Thank you, uh
Hunter.
Uh and this goes back a little bit. Um
it says I think the difference is they
are eating real food and we are eating
Captain Crunch. I think when you were
talking about other countries
not getting cancer as much. Um I've
actually heard testimonials from people
resolving their cancer through fasting
and eating only grass-fed organic beef.
So, I don't know if that's true or not,
but that um I know it does help people
if they eat healthy and they change
their diets that it can, you know, the
body is an amazing organism.
>> Absolutely. And you know, just to kind
of go on that thing, I'm not a fan of
glycosin, which is what makes rebound
work. And in Europe, it's been banned
because it's a car carcinogen. We've
already talked about that. And they
don't require it. And I really think
they should, but so much of our wheat in
the United States, they use rebound to
control the weeds in the wheat field
that the flower has the chemical in it.
But yet, they don't require the mills to
test it and measure it and say which
one. You actually have there's a few out
there, and I know I'm going to get
emails saying what are the few, so I
have to look them up again that uh that
actually test it. uh and they get their
wheat only from an organic
non-pesticide wheat field and it's
usually old strain to boot and that they
don't have it. But the main ones, the
big brands that you can think of that
you see in every store and I I'll even
toss out two brand names that I really
shouldn't. uh King Arthur, uh uh um
Pillsbury, Doughboy, uh Gold Medal, they
all do.
And and even Bob's Redm Mill, which is
kind of famous on the West Coast.
Does
um Oh, I just picked your favorite,
didn't I?
[laughter]
as she and I I just wish that they would
>> allow, you know, if you're going to have
all these rules with nutritional
products on what's on the label and
being fully dis transparent, why can't
they do it with the food? Well, that's
because of there's four major companies
to control 80% of what we eat and they
don't want it and they have enough power
in Congress to block it.
>> Yeah. They should put every single thing
that's in our food
>> cuz it isn't it isn't a hard test to do.
>> Uhuh.
>> It's not like you have to hire a PhD to
do it.
>> No, it's not. Um,
and
I was just going to say, oh, I used to
love Dr. Pepper,
but it's got antifreeze ingredients.
I don't even I Richard I don't think
I've had even like a seven up any kind
of soda uh in probably eight or nine
years.
I have not drank any soda. Every once in
a while I'll have like a seltzer water,
but it's like usually if I have an upset
tummy or something, but um I don't even
like the way it makes my body feel
because the bubbles, you know, they make
a belly bloat. It's awful. But um no um
King Arthur was is a flour that I use
when I would make gluten-free sourdough
bread. And he said that one and then
when you said red mill I'm like what
other options do we have? But that's a
whole other topic. Um Albert has his
hand up so we'll go to Albert because I
know you said you only had a few extra
minutes. So Albert
>> hi there Richard. I just wanted to ask
you mentioned um
rebound.
>> Uh oh, you're breaking up on me.
>> I think you were meaning to say round
up. Am I right?
>> Oh, when I say
>> you said rebound, has it?
>> Oh, no. Round up.
>> You mean round up.
>> Okay. So, I'll blame it on 71 years of
life.
>> Thank you, Albert. I was gonna ask that
question next. Thank you. [laughter]
>> So, it's round up, not rebound.
>> Round up, not rebound.
>> Say it, Richard. You have to say it.
>> It's round up, not rebound.
>> Okay, [laughter]
we're gonna get emails, you know. Thank
you, Albert. You're surprised.
>> All right, [clears throat]
so um I don't see any more questions
on my end. Um,
oh, Hunter
had says, "We know radiation can cause
it unless they're saying radiation
causes parasites."
And then he says, "I think they're t
taking the whole parasite thing too far
himself," [clears throat]
which I agree. And then, um, I hope you
heard that right, that I said beef and
not wheat. Yes, he did. Um, and then
Olga on YouTube is it says, "I had Fonda
once when I was a child and that was it.
No soda ever." Oh, kudos to you. I'm
very proud of you for that. And Haddie
as her her hand up again. So, it's 4:05
my time. You have a couple more minutes
and then we'll do the wrap-up or do you
want to need to end now? Oh,
>> well, let's let's let let Haddie in
there.
>> Okay. Okay, if you could unmute.
>> You know, it's it's it's you know, I
think you should just give us one good
example because all of those flowers you
mentioned, you know, one of them is one
is mine's too. So, if you could give me
a good one, I sure would appreciate
because I'm making a bunch of
gluten-free bread this weekend.
>> Oh. Oh, dear. Okay. So, uh, off top of
my head, I'm going to pull a blank, but
I will find out for you and I will email
it to Ruth Ellen and she can put it on
the Facebook page or she can mention it.
Is Ben on tomorrow?
>> No, not tomorrow. Friday.
>> Well, maybe you'll mention it before
he'll get going because he'll know about
it, too. So, uh, but I'll look it up and
get you the message and I'll I'll give
you three good ones.
>> Okay. I'll make sure to mention it
before our guest tomorrow. I just need
to confirm before I say that they're
going to be on.
>> Okay. Okay. Um, thank you, Haddie. I
have the [laughter] question, too. All
right. So, is there anything you'd like
to say to wrap up?
>> Well, I would say that, you know, there
again, everybody's different and so how
these products work, there's no absolute
just like there's no absolute in
anything in life, basically. and just
try to enjoy it as best we can and talk
to people because I think communicating
with people is as important as anything
else healthwise. If you locked yourself
in your house, you won't particularly
have a happy life. So, get out there and
enjoy life.
>> Yes, I agree. I agree very much. All
right, if I could get my co-hosts to
come up, then we'll wrap up. And while
they're coming on, I'd just like to say
that um thank you so much, Richard. You
are always amazing and I appreciate you
very much. Also, um this program was
only meant for educational purposes
only, not meant to treat, diagnose or
cure any diseases.
And uh the information
is pivotal in my [laughter] opinion to
everything. So, thank you again. Also,
this program is sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com.
And if you have any questions that
didn't get answered or um you can email
us at questionsailywithdoc.com
and Richard, if you have questions for
Richard, can I give your email address
out?
>> Sure.
>> It's Richard.com.
So if you have a question specifically
for him or want information of any kind
that he can provide, please email him.
And um also we have a team of holistic
health coaches that are available to
answer your call at 8559493377.
And if you are working with someone and
somebody referred you to this program,
like I said earlier, please make sure to
get back with them.
All right. So, thank you so much. And
AJ, can you bring yourself on? Thank
you. All right. So, we have um to my
right, we have Sherry who is part of the
tech crew. She helps me. We get on an
hour earlier and she helps me get
everything set up so that it's ready to
live stream. So, thank you for all that
you do, Sherry, because I really
appreciate that. And then Marilyn, Miss
Bey Fingers, who is an amazing typist
and she's out there typing what is said
and looking up definitions for things
and posting and still keeping up. So,
thank you for that, Marilyn. And then we
have Phyllis who is an amazing co-host
and
platform monitor and got Doc on the
radio and so many things. So, thank you
for all that you do. And then we have
Albert who's in South Africa who of
course answers the phone in the middle
of the night when we're sleeping. So he
is part of our phone team. He is our
gatekeeper and he is a true gentle man.
Just love you. And then we have AJ who
is our digital marketing director and he
helps us get out onto different
platforms and helps us with everything
digital marketing. So thank you for
that. and he is also part of our tech
crew and helps get everything set up.
So, thank you. Thank you, AJ. And I'm
Ruth Ellen Sanchez. I am the executive
production manager for Daily with Doc
Becca. And I just want to thank you all
for joining us today. And also, I have
to give a shout out to Becca Dukes who's
been on and just listening. Thank you so
much. And she is away. And uh we can't
wait for you to get back as always
because I miss you. I like game night.
We got to do more game night. All right,
everybody,
have a beautiful day and thank you so
much again, Richard. I can't wait to see
you again on the 22nd.
We will be there.
>> Bye for now, everybody.
This program is for educational.
purposes only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of [music] the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding [music] health or income. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
[music] Bachelor of Science in Plant and
Soil Sciences, Doctor of Veterary
Medicine, four post doctorates in
pathology, naturopathic doctor